Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was around 6.30pm on Saturday, October 24, 1953, when 15-year-old Evelyn Hartley left her home in the city of La Crosse, Wisconsin. Mature and trustworthy, Evelyn had been tasked with babysitting the 20-month-old daughter of one of her father's colleagues.
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集的节目说明。1953年10月24日星期六下午6点30分左右，15岁的伊芙琳·哈特利（Evelyn Hartley）离开了她位于威斯康星州拉克罗斯市的家。伊芙琳成熟可靠，受托照顾她父亲一位同事20个月大的女儿。
Evelyn had only been gone for half an hour when her mother, Ethel, was overcome by an urge to call Evelyn right away. She didn't know why, but she felt a need to check in with her daughter. Ethel expressed her concerns to her husband, Richard. He didn't share her worry. Prior to leaving, Evelyn said she would call her parents to touch base at 8.30pm. Richard had no doubt that their daughter, whom they called Evee, would ring in just over an hour's time as planned.
伊芙琳离开才半小时，她的母亲埃塞尔（Ethel）就产生了一种强烈的冲动，想立刻给伊芙琳打电话。她不知道为什么，但她觉得有必要确认一下女儿的情况。埃塞尔向丈夫理查德（Richard）表达了她的担忧。他并不认同她的焦虑。离开前，伊芙琳说她会在晚上8点30分打电话给父母报平安。理查德毫不怀疑，他们称之为“伊薇”（Evee）的女儿会像计划的那样，在一个多小时后打来电话。
But 8.30pm came and went without the promised phone call. Richard Hartley dialed the number for the Rasmussen family whom Evelyn was babysitting for. There was no answer. He tried again and again, but the phone continued to ring out. Wondering whether Evelyn might have gone to one of the Rasmussen's neighbors' homes for some reason, Richard started calling some of them. No one had seen his daughter.
但晚上8点30分过去了，约定的电话并没有打来。理查德·哈特利拨打了伊芙琳正在照看的拉斯穆森（Rasmussen）一家的电话。无人接听。他一次又一次地拨打，但电话始终无人接听。理查德心想伊芙琳是否因为某种原因去了拉斯穆森家邻居那里，于是开始给他们中的一些人打电话。没有人见过他的女儿。
By 9.15pm, Ethel Hartley was convinced something was terribly wrong. Richard drove straight to the Rasmussen's home, which was less than two miles away on Heschelow Drive. On their driveway, Richard could see lights on inside the residence. He could also hear music playing faintly on a radio. Feeling slightly reassured, Richard knocked on the front door. Evelyn didn't appear. He banged louder and rang the doorbell.
到了晚上9点15分，埃塞尔·哈特利确信出大事了。理查德直接开车前往位于赫舍洛大道（Heschelow Drive）上、距离不到两英里的拉斯穆森家。在他们的车道上，理查德可以看到住宅内亮着灯。他还能听到收音机里隐约传来的音乐声。理查德感到稍微安心了一些，便敲了敲前门。伊芙琳没有出现。他用力敲门并按了门铃。
Still, nobody came. Grabbing the door handle to let himself in, Richard found it was locked. He then peered through the front windows into the home's main living area. It looked as though no one was home. Richard hurried around to the back of the house where there was a rear door. It too was locked. He shouted while pounding on the door, but his efforts were in vain. As Richard paced the perimeter of the house, he suddenly tripped on something.
依然没有人来。理查德抓住门把手想自己进去，却发现门锁着。他随后透过前窗向屋内的主起居区望去。看起来好像家里没人。理查德匆忙绕到房子后面，那里有一扇后门。门也锁着。他一边用力敲门一边大喊，但他的努力徒劳无功。当理查德在房子周围踱步时，他突然被什么东西绊了一下。
A mesh screen had been removed from the basement window and was leaning against an exterior wall. The window was open and Richard was able to maneuver his body inside. As he lulled himself into the dark basement, his feet found a small stepladder below. He straightened up and turned on a light. Lying at the bottom of the stairs that led into the house above was a small black shoe with tassels. It belonged to Evelyn.
地下室窗户上的纱窗被拆了下来，靠在墙外。窗户开着，理查德设法钻了进去。当他把自己放进黑暗的地下室时，脚下碰到了一把小梯子。他站直身体，打开了灯。在通往楼上的楼梯底部，躺着一只带流苏的小黑鞋。那是伊芙琳的鞋。
The streets of La Crosse were quiet that evening as the annual homecoming football game was underway. The town's team of La Crosse State Teachers College was taking on their arch rivals River Falls. La Crosse State hadn't lost a game all season and their beloved captain was being recognized in a special ceremony. Someone who had been able to get a ticket was there. La Crosse State Teachers College, now known as the University of Wisconsin La Crosse,
那天晚上拉克罗斯的街道很安静，因为一年一度的返校橄榄球赛正在进行。镇上的拉克罗斯州立师范学院队正在迎战他们的死敌河瀑队（River Falls）。拉克罗斯州立队整个赛季未尝败绩，他们深受爱戴的队长还在一场特别仪式上受到了表彰。有幸买到票的人都在那里。拉克罗斯州立师范学院，现称为威斯康星大学拉克罗斯分校，
was a big part of the small Riverside City's identity. Although it only had 945 students, the college played a significant role in the community. It employed a number of its residents, including physics professor Vigo Rasmussen. Vigo was looking forward to the homecoming game, which he planned to attend with his wife and 7-year-old daughter. But his other daughter, 20-month-old Janice, was too young to join them. About a week before the game, Vigo reached out to the family's regular babysitter to see if she could watch Janice on the night of Saturday, October 24.
是这座小型河滨城市身份的重要组成部分。尽管只有945名学生，但该学院在社区中发挥着重要作用。它雇佣了许多当地居民，包括物理学教授维戈·拉斯穆森（Vigo Rasmussen）。维戈很期待这场返校比赛，他计划和妻子以及7岁的女儿一起参加。但他另一个20个月大的女儿珍妮丝（Janice）太小了，无法和他们一起去。比赛前一周左右，维戈联系了家里的常驻保姆，看她能否在10月24日星期六晚上照看珍妮丝。
She couldn't help as she was going to the game also. Vigo's regular babysitter was the daughter of a colleague, so Vigo again asked around at work to find a replacement. Biology professor Richard Hartley had a studious and kind 15-year-old daughter named Evelyn who came highly recommended. When Vigo asked if she would be able to watch Janice in a week's time, Evelyn agreed. Evelyn soon began to have second thoughts. She had a bad feeling about the job, plus she wasn't keen on staying in while everyone
她帮不上忙，因为她也要去看比赛。维戈的常驻保姆是他一位同事的女儿，所以维戈又在工作中四处打听寻找替代人选。生物学教授理查德·哈特利有一个勤奋善良的15岁女儿，名叫伊芙琳，她受到了高度推荐。当维戈问她一周后是否能照看珍妮丝时，伊芙琳同意了。伊芙琳很快开始有了顾虑。她对这份工作有一种不好的预感，而且她也不想在每个人都在返校比赛中玩得开心时待在家里。
else was having fun at the homecoming game. Evelyn wondered aloud if she could back out of the agreement. Her mother Ethel reminded her that she'd made a commitment to the Rasmussen's and should do the right thing by sticking to it. When Saturday night arrived, Evelyn packed several textbooks so she could study while Janice slept and waited for Vigo Rasmussen to collect her as planned. Before leaving she promised to call her parents at 8.30 to check in as she always did when she babysat.
伊芙琳大声问自己是否可以退出这个约定。她的母亲埃塞尔提醒她，她已经对拉斯穆森一家做出了承诺，应该信守承诺，做正确的事。周六晚上到来时，伊芙琳带了几本教科书，这样她可以在珍妮丝睡觉时学习，并等待维戈·拉斯穆森按计划来接她。离开前，她答应像往常做保姆时那样，在8点30分给父母打电话报平安。
Vigo Rasmussen picked Evelyn up at 6.30pm and drove her back to his family's house. Evelyn set up her textbooks in the living room and Madeline Rasmussen, Vigo's wife, gave her instructions. It was going to be a straightforward night. Janice was to go to bed at 7 o'clock and then all Evelyn would have to do was check in on her at 7.15 and cover her with a blanket. At 6.45pm the Rasmussen said goodbye to Evelyn and headed to watch the game. Two and a half hours later, Richard Hartley stood in the basement of the Rasmussen home.
维戈·拉斯穆森在下午6点30分接上伊芙琳，开车把她送回了家。伊芙琳在客厅里摆好教科书，维戈的妻子玛德琳·拉斯穆森（Madeline Rasmussen）给了她一些指示。这将是一个简单的夜晚。珍妮丝要在7点钟上床睡觉，然后伊芙琳所要做的就是7点15分去看看她，并给她盖上毯子。下午6点45分，拉斯穆森夫妇和伊芙琳道别，前往观看比赛。两个半小时后，理查德·哈特利站在了拉斯穆森家的地下室里。
He'd let himself in through an open window to find out why his daughter wasn't answering the home's phone or door. Having come across one of Evelyn's shoes at the base of the stairs, Richard raced up to the main part of the house. Evelyn's schoolbooks were scattered across the living room. Her brand new eyeglasses were lying on the floor, as was her other black shoe. Smeared across the light-colored rug was a muddy shoe print. There were also several drops of blood.
他通过一扇开着的窗户钻了进来，想弄清楚为什么女儿不接家里的电话也不开门。在楼梯底部发现伊芙琳的一只鞋后，理查德冲向房子的主区域。伊芙琳的课本散落在客厅里。她崭新的眼镜掉在地板上，另一只黑鞋也是。浅色的地毯上涂抹着一个泥泞的鞋印。还有几滴血迹。
Richard checked the rest of the house. Janice was unharmed and fast asleep in her crib. But Evelyn was nowhere to be found. Local police were preparing to go home after a quiet night when a call came through at 9.49pm about a missing teenage girl. They weren't overly concerned, believing the girl had likely gone to see a boy and would be found within 10 minutes. Two officers arrived at the Rasmussen residence, where Richard Hartley was waiting to meet them.
理查德检查了房子的其余部分。珍妮丝安然无恙，在婴儿床上睡得很熟。但伊芙琳却不见踪影。当地警方在平静的夜晚准备下班时，在晚上9点49分接到了一个关于一名少女失踪的电话。他们并没有太担心，认为女孩很可能是去见男朋友了，10分钟内就会被找到。两名警官抵达拉斯穆森住所，理查德·哈特利正在那里等候他们。
The officers soon realized how serious the situation was. Over a dozen more officers arrived, along with detectives, the district attorney, and the La Crosse County Sheriff. The Rasmissons had moved into the house just a few months earlier. The ordinary ranch-style suburban home had three bedrooms. It was part of a new subdivision, and like many other residences in the neighborhood, it was so new that its windows had no blinds or curtains. It sat close to other houses on the street, and there were enough people around that it
警官们很快意识到情况的严重性。十几名警官赶到现场，还有侦探、地方检察官和拉克罗斯县警长。拉斯穆森一家几个月前才搬进这所房子。这栋普通的牧场式郊区住宅有三间卧室。它是新开发区的一部分，和邻里的许多其他住宅一样，它太新了，窗户上没有百叶窗或窗帘。它靠近街上的其他房子，周围有足够多的人，即使在这样一个安静的夜晚，
didn't feel isolated or remote, even on a quiet night like this. Outside, investigators noticed someone had used a screwdriver to try and pry open three separate windows. A flower bed below one window featured an imprint of a size 11 tennis shoe, matching the muddy shoe print on the living room rug. After failing to jimmy the other windows open, the intruder finally succeeded with the basement window. Several red fibers on its surface matched the jeans Evelyn Hartley had been wearing that
它也不显得孤立或偏远。在外面，调查人员注意到有人曾用螺丝刀试图撬开三扇不同的窗户。其中一扇窗户下的花坛里有一个11码网球鞋的印记，与客厅地毯上的泥泞鞋印相符。在未能撬开其他窗户后，入侵者最终成功打开了地下室的窗户。窗户表面上的几根红色纤维与伊芙琳·哈特利那天晚上穿的牛仔裤相符。
evening. Whoever had broken into the basement had forced the 15-year-old out via the same route. While it was initially thought the intruder had placed the step ladder under the basement window to secure their escape, the Rasmussen's revealed that they had propped the ladder there on a previous occasion. The fact it sat in such an opportune location for the abductor was merely a coincidence. Traces of blood were found inside the basement, with more just outside about 10 feet from the window.
无论谁闯入了地下室，都通过同样的路线强行带走了这名15岁的女孩。虽然最初认为入侵者是将梯子放在地下室窗户下以确保逃脱，但拉斯穆森一家透露，他们之前曾把梯子靠在那里。它处于对绑架者如此有利的位置纯属巧合。地下室里发现了血迹，窗外约10英尺处也有更多血迹。
A large pool of blood on the ground nearby was consistent with a severely injured person having laid down there to recover. A bloody handprint was smeared across the outside wall of the Rasmussen house. Another was found on the exterior of a neighbor's garage about 100 yards away. Pools of blood lined an external wall of a third house just around the corner. The blood was Type A, the same as Evelyn's. Bloodhounds tracked the scent for two blocks but then stopped. It seemed Evelyn had been forced into a vehicle there and whisked away.
附近地上的一大滩血迹与一个受重伤的人躺在那里恢复体力的情况相符。拉斯穆森家外墙上涂抹着一个血手印。大约100码外的一位邻居的车库外也发现了一个。拐角处第三栋房子的外墙边有一滩血迹。血型是A型，和伊芙琳的一样。警犬追踪气味走了两个街区，但随后停了下来。看来伊芙琳在那里被强行塞进了一辆车，然后被带走了。
An alert was issued and descriptions of Evelyn Hartley were sent out. At foot 7, 126 pounds, straight brown hair and blue eyes, last seen wearing red jeans rolled up at the cuff, bobby socks and a white blouse. Janice Rasmussen was in her crib but was not covered in a blanket. This led investigators to assume that Evelyn was confronted within the 15 minute window between Janice's bed time at 7 and 7.15 when Evelyn was supposed to cover Janice with a blanket. Evelyn's attacker likely gave her a bloody nose which had caused the initial blood spots
警方发布了警报，并发送了伊芙琳·哈特利的描述。身高5英尺7英寸（约1.7米），体重126磅（约57公斤），直棕发，蓝眼睛，最后一次露面时穿着卷边的红色牛仔裤、短袜和白色衬衫。珍妮丝·拉斯穆森在婴儿床上，但没有盖毯子。这导致调查人员推测，伊芙琳是在珍妮丝7点睡觉到7点15分伊芙琳本应给她盖毯子之间的15分钟窗口期内遭遇袭击的。伊芙琳的袭击者很可能让她流了鼻血，这导致了客厅地毯上最初的血点。
on the living room rug. Once outside the basement, the attacker had hit Evelyn with the window screen causing a greater injury. Evelyn had lost significant amounts of blood as her abductor forced her away from the Rasmussen home. She stopped periodically causing her blood to pool in certain areas. The bloody handprints were from Evelyn dragging her hand along the buildings they passed. When Richard Hartley saw the blood the next morning in the harsh light of day, he feared
一旦到了地下室外，袭击者就用窗纱击打了伊芙琳，造成了更严重的伤害。当绑架者强行将伊芙琳带离拉斯穆森家时，她流失了大量的血。她不时停下来，导致她的血在某些区域汇集。血手印是伊芙琳在经过建筑物时拖着手留下的。当理查德·哈特利第二天早上在刺眼的日光下看到血迹时，他担心
his daughter hadn't survived her ordeal. There was simply too much. It was a particularly tragic thought as Ethel and Richard Hartley had already lost their eldest son to Polio seven years earlier. Ethel was too distraught to leave her home until Monday when she was taken to the Rasmussen house and escorted through the crime scene. She remained calm as she looked at the living room and the basement. But when Ethel saw the blood outside, she broke down and lent on her husband for support.
女儿没能挺过这场磨难。血实在太多了。这是一个特别悲惨的想法，因为埃塞尔和理查德·哈特利七年前已经失去了他们的大儿子，死于小儿麻痹症。埃塞尔悲痛欲绝，直到周一才离开家，当时她被带到拉斯穆森家，并被护送穿过犯罪现场。她在查看客厅和地下室时保持冷静。但当埃塞尔看到外面的血迹时，她崩溃了，靠在丈夫身上寻求支撑。
Oh, my Evelyn, she cried. We know she isn't alive now. People in La Crosse had been so absorbed by the football game the night prior that it wasn't until they gathered for Sunday church that news of Evelyn Hartley's abduction spread. Hundreds of locals soon descended on the Rasmussen property to offer assistance or gawk at investigators. Police had to cordon off two blocks around the house to prevent the scene from becoming contaminated.
“哦，我的伊芙琳，”她哭喊道。“我们现在知道她已经不在人世了。”拉克罗斯的人们前一天晚上完全沉浸在橄榄球比赛中，直到周日去教堂聚会时，伊芙琳·哈特利被绑架的消息才传开。数百名当地人很快涌向拉斯穆森的房产，提供帮助或围观调查人员。警方不得不封锁了房子周围的两个街区，以防止现场受到破坏。
Although night had already fallen by the time Evelyn was taken, the moon was bright and street lamps were lit. Like the Rasmussen's, many residents along Heschler Drive had yet to install curtains or blinds in their newly built homes. Thus, they could see directly outside. Across the street, a couple had sat listening to music in a room with a clear view of the Rasmussen's house. Another man had been painting his basement's interior.
虽然伊芙琳被带走时夜幕已经降临，但月亮很亮，路灯也亮着。和拉斯穆森一家一样，赫舍洛大道沿线的许多居民尚未在他们新建的家中安装窗帘或百叶窗。因此，他们可以直接看到外面。街对面，一对夫妇坐着听音乐，房间里可以清楚地看到拉斯穆森家。另一个人一直在粉刷他地下室的内部。
These was one of the homes that was smeared with Evelyn's blood. Many other neighbors were home as well. One had even been doing some late night gardening. Despite this, no one had seen Evelyn or her assailant coming or going. However, Elven Sotterbach had been sitting on his front porch at around 7 that night when two or three sharp screams suddenly rang out. Elven couldn't tell where the screams had originated, but they sounded to him like children playing.
这是涂抹着伊芙琳血迹的房子之一。许多其他邻居也在家。甚至有一个人一直在进行深夜园艺。尽管如此，没有人看到伊芙琳或她的袭击者来去。然而，埃尔文·索特巴赫（Elven Sotterbach）那天晚上7点左右正坐在前廊上，突然传来了两三声尖锐的尖叫声。埃尔文说不出尖叫声来自哪里，但听起来像是孩子们在玩耍。
The final cry cut off abruptly as though interrupted by something or someone. Elven thought a parent had intervened to discipline the unruly children. Elven's wife, who was in the kitchen, also heard the screams. She thought they sounded less playful than her husband did. After her, it sounded like whoever was screaming was sending a message of, stop, get away from me. That night, Ed Hoffa had been driving through the area to pick up his brother-in-law en route to the homecoming game.
最后的哭声戛然而止，仿佛被什么东西或什么人打断了。埃尔文以为是家长介入管教那些不听话的孩子。埃尔文的妻子当时在厨房里，也听到了尖叫声。她觉得听起来不像她丈夫说的那么像玩耍。对她来说，听起来像是尖叫的人在传达一种“停下，离我远点”的信息。那天晚上，埃德·霍法（Ed Hoffa）正开车穿过该地区，去接他的姐夫前往返校比赛。
At 7.15pm, Ed pulled into Sunrise Drive, which ran parallel to Hesla Drive. His car's headlights illuminated several people walking along the footpath. It was two young men, with the young woman sandwiched between them. The girl was staggering as though she'd had a few drinks. Ed paid them little attention as he pulled over and headed inside his brother-in-law's house. Five minutes later, Ed was driving again with his brother-in-law riding his passenger. He headed north on Sunrise.
晚上7点15分，埃德驶入与赫舍洛大道平行的日出大道（Sunrise Drive）。他汽车的前灯照亮了人行道上行走的几个人。那是两个年轻人，中间夹着一个年轻女子。女孩摇摇晃晃，好像喝了几杯酒。埃德没怎么注意他们，就把车停在路边，走进了他姐夫的房子。五分钟后，埃德再次开车，姐夫坐在副驾驶座上。他沿着日出大道向北行驶。
A dark green two-toned 1942 Buick suddenly careened past in the opposite direction. Its driver was speeding, but Ed still managed to catch a glimpse inside as the car whizzed by. He was certain the car's occupants were the three young people he'd passed on the street minutes earlier. One of the men was driving, the other sat in the back seat next to the woman. She was slumped forward, her head pressed against the back of the driver's seat. It looked as though she might have been unwell.
一辆深绿色双色调的1942年别克车突然从相反方向疾驰而过。司机开得很快，但埃德在车子呼啸而过时还是瞥了一眼车内。他确信车里的人就是他几分钟前在街上经过的那三个年轻人。其中一个男人在开车，另一个坐在女人旁边的后座上。她向前瘫倒，头靠在驾驶座的靠背上。看起来她可能身体不适。
Ed had written off the incident at the time as young people having fun. On Monday, he was at work when he heard that a 15-year-old girl had been abducted from a house just around the corner. Ed then reported his recollections to the police. He hadn't been able to get a good look at the car's driver. He thought the man behind the wheel might have been a local college student, but when police followed up with the student, they found he had an airtight alibi. Pitches of a car matching the Buick's description were given to petrol stations in the area,
埃德当时把这件事归结为年轻人在玩乐。周一，他在上班时听说一名15岁女孩在拐角处的房子里被绑架了。埃德随后向警方报告了他的回忆。他没能看清车司机的长相。他认为开车的人可能是当地的一名大学生，但当警方跟进调查那名学生时，发现他有不在场证明。警方将符合别克车描述的汽车照片分发给该地区的加油站，
with employees told to keep an eye out for similar vehicles. Police also set up an incentive for people to volunteer their vehicles for searching. Members of the public were encouraged to drive to local petrol stations and allow the station's employees to check the back seat and trunk of their cars. Once they had been given the all-clear, they would be given a sticker that read, my car is okay. The sticker would be displayed in the car's window, along with the date of the search. Any drivers who refused to comply with the search had their details noted by the petrol
并告诉员工留意类似的车辆。警方还设立了一种激励措施，鼓励人们自愿让他们的车辆接受搜查。公众被鼓励开车到当地加油站，让加油站员工检查他们汽车的后座和后备箱。一旦确认没有问题，他们就会得到一张写着“我的车没问题”的贴纸。贴纸会贴在车窗上，并标明搜查日期。任何拒绝配合搜查的司机，其详细信息都会被加油站员工记录下来并转交给警方。
station employees who passed them on to police. 40,000 stickers were printed, and the aim was to search every car in the county. Ted Hoffer's sighting indicated that Evelyn was taken by two men working together. The question still remained, was it an opportunistic or planned abduction? Nothing had been stolen from the Rasmussen house, but maybe the man had broken in only to be surprised by Evelyn. As she had been covering for the family's regular babysitter, some speculated that perhaps the other girl was the original target.
印制了4万张贴纸，目的是搜查县里的每一辆车。泰德·霍法（Ted Hoffer）的目击情况表明，伊芙琳是被两名合作的男子带走的。问题依然存在：这是一起机会主义绑架还是有预谋的绑架？拉斯穆森家什么也没丢，但也许那个人闯入只是为了寻找财物，却被伊芙琳撞见了。由于她是替家里常驻保姆代班，有人推测也许另一个女孩才是最初的目标。
The media wondered whether Evelyn Hartley was as squeaky clean as everyone believed. What if she had a secret life and ran away with a boy? This notion was entirely dismissed by investigators and everyone who knew her. It was far more probable that a pair of prowlers had taken advantage of the quiet streets that night to look for potential victims. One woman reported that recently she had been ironing clothes in her basement only to look up to see an unknown man staring through a window at her. He laughed and said, I'm going to get you.
媒体想知道伊芙琳·哈特利是否像每个人认为的那样清白。如果她有秘密生活并和一个男孩私奔了呢？这个想法被调查人员和所有认识她的人完全否定了。更有可能的是，一对徘徊者利用那天晚上安静的街道寻找潜在的受害者。一名妇女报告说，最近她在地下室熨衣服时，抬头看到一个陌生男人正透过窗户盯着她。他笑着说：“我要抓住你。”
Investigators tracked down a man who was known to spy through people's windows. They also interviewed a man who had been convicted of sexually abusing his 12-year-old daughter six years earlier. Neither of these lines of inquiry led anywhere, nor did interviews with 48 other men who were wanted for or associated with the various sex crimes. Richard Hartley and Avigo Rasmussen were also looked into, but more so out of procedure than anything else. Both men cooperated with authorities and were ruled out of the investigation.
调查人员追踪到了一个以透过别人窗户窥探而闻名的男人。他们还采访了一个六年前因性虐待自己12岁女儿而被定罪的男人。这些调查方向都没有任何结果，对其他48名因各种性犯罪而被通缉或与之有关的男子的采访也是如此。理查德·哈特利和维戈·拉斯穆森也受到了调查，但这更多是出于程序而非其他原因。两名男子都配合了当局，并被排除了嫌疑。
The cross residents, businesses and organizations pulled together a reward for information that was the equivalent of almost $71,500 today. Upwards of 2,000 people joined the search for Evelyn. Bodies of water were dragged, farmers scoured their fields and hunters were on the lookout while in the woods. Recently dug graves at cemeteries were checked in case Evelyn's attacker had thought to use one as an easy way to dispose of her. Many of those searching for Evelyn were her peers from her school.
拉克罗斯的居民、企业和组织共同筹集了一笔悬赏金，相当于今天的近71,500美元。超过2,000人加入了寻找伊芙琳的行列。人们打捞了水体，农民搜寻了他们的田地，猎人在树林里时也保持警惕。墓地里新挖的坟墓也被检查了，以防伊芙琳的袭击者想利用其中一个作为处理她的简便方法。许多寻找伊芙琳的人都是她学校的同学。
They were joined by the local Boy Scouts and other community groups. Amongst the crowd was Evelyn's 22-year-old brother, Thomas. He had rushed home from college upon learning of Evelyn's disappearance. Thomas and a friend covered three miles of La Crosse, removing manholes and then jumping down into the storm sewers to check for Evelyn. When it grew dark, Thomas became upset. He didn't want to stop looking for his little sister. Wednesday, October 28 marked four days since Evelyn Hartley went missing.
当地童子军和其他社区团体也加入了他们的行列。人群中还有伊芙琳22岁的哥哥托马斯（Thomas）。他在得知伊芙琳失踪后从大学赶回家。托马斯和一个朋友搜寻了拉克罗斯的三英里区域，移开井盖，然后跳进雨水下水道寻找伊芙琳。天黑时，托马斯很难过。他不想停止寻找他的小妹妹。10月28日星期三，距离伊芙琳·哈特利失踪已经四天了。
Highway 14, two miles south of La Crosse's city limits had been searched the previous day to no result. Yet, on Wednesday, a bra and a pair of women's underwear were recovered from the area. The garments were a popular brand and appeared to be Evelyn's size. Given they hadn't been spotted previously, it was believed that they'd been dumped within the past 24 hours. They appeared to have been thrown from a moving vehicle that was fleeing south. Both garments were stained with type A blood.
拉克罗斯市界以南两英里的14号公路前一天已被搜查，但没有结果。然而，在周三，该地区发现了一件胸罩和一条女式内裤。这些衣物是一个受欢迎的品牌，看起来是伊芙琳的尺码。鉴于之前没有发现它们，人们认为它们是在过去24小时内被丢弃的。它们似乎是从一辆向南逃窜的行驶车辆中扔出来的。两件衣物上都沾有A型血。
As roughly 40% of the population had this blood type, police couldn't be certain it was Evelyn's. These later, on Friday, October 31, a third search of Highway 14 was undertaken. Close to where the bra and underwear had been found, a search party came across two size 11 good-rich brand sneakers. They too had seemingly been tossed one at a time from a vehicle travelling south. The pattern on the soles of the sneakers matched the muddy prints found in the Rasmussen home. They had a distinctive circular wear pattern as well, which suggested whoever owned them
由于大约40%的人口有这种血型，警方无法确定这一定是伊芙琳的。几天后，即10月31日星期五，对14号公路进行了第三次搜查。在发现胸罩和内裤的地方附近，搜查队发现了两只11码的古德里奇（Goodrich）品牌运动鞋。它们似乎也是从一辆向南行驶的车辆中一只一只扔出来的。运动鞋鞋底的图案与在拉斯穆森家发现的泥泞鞋印相符。它们还有一个独特的圆形磨损图案，这表明拥有它们的人
worked with some kind of machinery. The shoes also had type A blood on them. It was determined that they had been worn by two different people, one whose feet was a size larger than the sneakers. This particular model of sneaker was called the Hood Mogul. They'd been available throughout Wisconsin, Iowa, Michigan, Minnesota and Illinois, but hadn't been sold in Wisconsin for about three years. An unusual marking on the back of the shoes was traced back to a Whizzer motorbike, meaning
从事某种机械工作。鞋子上也有A型血。经确定，它们是由两个人穿过的，其中一个人的脚比运动鞋大一码。这种特定的运动鞋型号被称为“胡德大亨”（Hood Mogul）。它们在威斯康星州、爱荷华州、密歇根州、明尼苏达州和伊利诺伊州都有销售，但在威斯康星州已经有大约三年没有销售了。鞋子背面一个不寻常的标记被追溯到一辆惠泽尔（Whizzer）摩托车，这意味着
whoever owned the shoes also rode this make of motorcycle. Registration and sales records for Whizzer motorbikes were checked, but the line of inquiry went nowhere. Two and a half weeks later, rumours had reached detectives pertaining to a blood-stained jacket. It had been found about 300 feet from where the sneakers were discovered. Rumours had noticed the jacket lying on the highway's shoulder as they drove past each day. One had picked it up and thrown it in the back of his truck, then promptly forgot about
拥有这些鞋子的人也骑这种品牌的摩托车。警方检查了惠泽尔摩托车的登记和销售记录，但这条调查线索毫无进展。两周半后，侦探们收到了关于一件血迹斑斑的夹克的传闻。它是在距离发现运动鞋的地方约300英尺处被发现的。传闻说有人每天开车经过时都注意到这件夹克躺在公路路肩上。其中一人把它捡起来扔进了卡车的后部，然后很快就忘了它。
it. The police identified the farmer and took possession of the jacket. It was denim and looked like the kind of jacket worn by people who worked outdoors. It had been cut along the bottom, then re-hemmed with a sewing machine using white thread. This had resulted in strange, shallow pockets and, like the shoes, it had spots of type A blood on it, on the front, back and the sleeves. Smears of blood in the Rasmussen home looked to be the result of a denim type fabric being rubbed against surfaces.
警方确认了那名农民并拿到了这件夹克。它是牛仔布做的，看起来像是户外工作者穿的那种夹克。它的底部被剪开，然后用缝纫机用白线重新缝边。这导致了奇怪的浅口袋，而且像鞋子一样，它的正面、背面和袖子上都有A型血点。拉斯穆森家里的血迹看起来像是牛仔布料摩擦表面造成的。
It seemed unlikely that the person who owned the shoes had also owned the jacket. The size 11 shoes indicated a taller owner, whereas a size 36 jacket would belong to a smaller man. Once again, clues in the case seemed to point to two perpetrators. The jacket had faded spots under the armpits, possibly caused by a safety harness commonly worn by people who worked as steeplejacks. They climbed tall structures like chimneys and steeples to carry out repairs. Detectives learned that a local man had manufactured safety harnesses for two steeplejacks the
拥有鞋子的人似乎不太可能也拥有这件夹克。11码的鞋子表明主人个子较高，而36码的夹克则属于一个较小的人。案件中的线索再次似乎指向两名肇事者。夹克腋下有褪色的斑点，可能是由高空作业者（steeplejacks）通常穿的安全带造成的。他们攀爬烟囱和尖塔等高大结构进行维修。侦探们了解到，一名当地男子在前一年为两名高空作业者制造了安全带，
previous year, but all he remembered about them was that they were young and possibly from the area. These had the bloodied jacket and shoes toured through 31 different towns within a 40-mile radius of La Crosse. They were displayed at local fairs and in public places in hopes someone would recognise them. As all their leads dried up, investigators sought to polygraph test every male student and school faculty member within the area. This would amount to a total of around 1,750 tests, making it the largest mass polygraph
但他对他们的记忆只有他们很年轻，可能来自该地区。警方带着血迹斑斑的夹克和鞋子巡回了拉克罗斯方圆40英里内的31个不同城镇。它们在当地集市和公共场所展出，希望有人能认出它们。随着所有线索中断，调查人员试图对该地区的所有男性学生和学校教职员工进行测谎测试。这将总共达到约1,750次测试，使其成为美国历史上最大规模的测谎
examination in United States history. Students cooperated without complaint. They were asked questions such as, are you withholding any information regarding the Evelyn Hartley disappearance case? Psychologist Dr Carl Smith was critical of the strategy. He told the Associated Press, This is a dangerous use of a device that is not even recognised in the courts. The tests, even though allegedly on a voluntary basis, are equivalent to a beating.
检查。学生们毫无怨言地配合了。他们被问及诸如“你是否隐瞒了任何关于伊芙琳·哈特利失踪案的信息？”之类的问题。心理学家卡尔·史密斯（Carl Smith）博士对这一策略持批评态度。他告诉美联社：“这是一种危险地使用甚至未在法庭上得到认可的设备。这些测试，尽管据称是自愿的，但等同于殴打。”
There actually is nothing voluntary about submitting to the tests, however, because if a pupil fails to submit, he will be suspected by members of his society. No one in the La Crosse community voiced any concerns about the process, but the school board ultimately put a stop to it. Around 300 boys had already been questioned. None of the information gathered proved fruitful. Every night since Evelyn disappeared, her family left all of the lights on in their house, believing it would help her find her way back to them.
“然而，实际上接受这些测试并没有什么自愿可言，因为如果学生不提交，他就会受到社会成员的怀疑。”拉克罗斯社区没有人对这一过程表示担忧，但学校董事会最终叫停了它。大约300名男生已经被问话。收集到的所有信息都没有证明是有用的。自从伊芙琳失踪以来，她的家人每天晚上都把家里所有的灯都开着，相信这会帮助她找到回家的路。
They also fronted the media, begging for those who knew anything about Evelyn's whereabouts to come forward. They soon received two phone calls from a man who said he had information about Evelyn. He would give it to them in exchange for $500 cash. It was to be placed inside a paper bag, then left in the bathroom of a La Crosse drugstore. The man said he would leave a letter in the bathroom that revealed Evelyn's whereabouts. The family was warned not to go to the police. With the money in her possession, Ethel Hartley headed into the store.
他们还面对媒体，恳求那些知道伊芙琳下落的人站出来。他们很快接到了一个男人的两个电话，他说他有关于伊芙琳的信息。他愿意用它来换取500美元现金。钱要放在一个纸袋里，然后留在拉克罗斯一家药店的洗手间里。那个人说他会在洗手间留下一封信，揭示伊芙琳的下落。家人被警告不要报警。带着钱，埃塞尔·哈特利走进了商店。
She went up a flight of stairs to the balcony where the bathrooms were located. Ethel looked for the letter the man said would be there, but there was nothing. She then left. The entire time a 13-year-old boy was following Ethel. When she walked out of the drugstore, the boy returned to the shop's main floor. There, he met up with a 20-year-old man named Jack Dufferin. Unbeknownst to Dufferin and the boy, plainclothes police officers were stationed throughout the store.
她走上一段楼梯来到洗手间所在的阳台。埃塞尔寻找那个人说会有的信，但什么也没有。然后她离开了。整个过程中，一个13岁的男孩一直跟着埃塞尔。当她走出药店时，男孩回到了商店的主楼层。在那里，他遇到了一个名叫杰克·达弗林（Jack Dufferin）的20岁男子。达弗林和那个男孩不知道的是，便衣警察驻扎在整个商店里。
Despite being warned not to, the Hartleys had told investigators about the phone call from the start. Both Dufferin and the boy were arrested, with Dufferin insisting he had nothing to do with it. There was nothing to tie him to Evelyn's abduction, but he was convicted of extortion and sentenced to one to three years. After this, the Hartleys avoided publicity. They decided to leave the case to the police and deal with their grief and anguish in private.
尽管被警告不要这样做，但哈特利一家从一开始就告诉了调查人员关于电话的事。达弗林和那个男孩都被逮捕了，达弗林坚称他与此事无关。没有任何证据将他与伊芙琳的绑架联系起来，但他因敲诈勒索被定罪，并被判处一至三年监禁。此后，哈特利一家避免了公开露面。他们决定把案件留给警方，私下处理他们的悲伤和痛苦。
But they were never left alone. In November 1953, Richard Hartleys received a letter. Postmarks revealed it had been sent from North Dakota, specifically the Devil's Lake area. It read, Just a note to let you know that Miss Hartleys is in my power. Don't try to trace this letter because I didn't leave any evidence. I'll let you know the ransom later. You stupid people almost had me, but I managed to escape.
但他们从未被单独留下。1953年11月，理查德·哈特利收到了一封信。邮戳显示它是从北达科他州寄出的，具体是魔鬼湖（Devil's Lake）地区。信上写着：“只是写个便条让你知道哈特利小姐在我的控制之下。不要试图追踪这封信，因为我没有留下任何证据。我稍后会让你知道赎金。你们这些愚蠢的人差点抓到我，但我设法逃脱了。”
Scribbled on the letter was a drawing of a skull and crossbones. Then in 1958, Evelyn's mother received a parcel that contained a girl's gym shirt. There was no explanation and apparently no link to Evelyn, though a note from the sender stated that the shirt would be of some interest to Ethel. That same year, a man with a wild stare showed up at the Hartleys' home and ranted about knowing where Evelyn was. Police handled the matter, but the man returned four days later. After visiting the Hartleys, he headed to the home of the Rasmussen's.
信上潦草地画着一个骷髅和交叉骨。然后，在1958年，伊芙琳的母亲收到一个包裹，里面有一件女孩的体操衫。没有解释，显然与伊芙琳没有联系，尽管寄件人的一张便条称这件衬衫会让埃塞尔感兴趣。同年，一个眼神狂野的男人出现在哈特利家，咆哮着说他知道伊芙琳在哪里。警方处理了此事，但那个人四天后又回来了。在拜访了哈特利一家后，他前往了拉斯穆森家。
They had since moved to a new house, unable to bear living in the place where Evelyn was taken. Both families were terrified of the man, who appeared to be a religious fanatic prone to nonsensical rants. He continued to be fixated by the case, sending long confusing letters to investigators and making anonymous calls asking for leads. As far as detectives could tell, his only connection to Evelyn Hartley was an unhealthy obsession with her disappearance.
他们已经搬到了新房子，无法忍受住在伊芙琳被带走的地方。两个家庭都对这个男人感到恐惧，他似乎是一个容易胡言乱语的宗教狂热分子。他继续纠结于此案，给调查人员寄去冗长混乱的信件，并打匿名电话询问线索。据侦探们所知，他与伊芙琳·哈特利唯一的联系就是对她失踪的不健康痴迷。
He wasn't the only one. The police received countless letters, phone calls and tip-offs from people certain they knew where Evelyn was or who had taken her. Some were clairvoyance, others spoke of having prophetic dreams that solved the case. Multiple individuals falsely confessed to the crime, including at least two men in mental health facilities. On several occasions, teenage girls and young women claimed to be Evelyn Hartley. Although the Hartleys insisted they were happy with the police's work and believed they would
他不是唯一一个。警方收到了无数的信件、电话和举报，来自那些确信自己知道伊芙琳在哪里或谁带走她的人。有些人是千里眼，另一些人谈到有解决案件的预言梦。多个人虚假承认了罪行，包括至少两名在精神卫生机构的男子。在几次场合中，少女和年轻女性声称自己是伊芙琳·哈特利。尽管哈特利一家坚持认为他们对警方的工作感到满意，并相信他们会
solve the case, other locals were disgruntled. Some remarked, if you want to get away with murder, move to La Crosse. They were also angry that the FBI hadn't become involved in the investigation, as they typically did with kidnappings. The La Crosse law enforcement had apparently asked for the FBI's assistance from the outset, but described the case as a sex crime, not an abduction. Consequently, the FBI refused to get involved. 84-year-old Howard George knew he didn't have much time left and wanted to spend his
破案，但其他当地人却心怀不满。有些人评论说：“如果你想逍遥法外，就搬到拉克罗斯去。”他们还对联邦调查局（FBI）没有参与调查感到愤怒，因为他们通常会处理绑架案。拉克罗斯执法部门显然从一开始就请求联邦调查局的协助，但将此案描述为性犯罪，而非绑架。因此，联邦调查局拒绝介入。84岁的霍华德·乔治（Howard George）知道自己时日无多，想在去世前以有意义的方式花掉他的
money in a meaningful way before he passed. Solving La Crosse's most enduring and painful mystery seemed like the obvious answer. So in 1958, Howard hired some private detectives to look into Evelyn Hartley's disappearance. They hit a roadblock when La Crosse police wouldn't share their files with them. As a result, they wasted time, resources and money looking into suspects who had already been cleared. When Howard George's actions became publicly known, his small and modest home was ransacked, although nothing was stolen.
钱。解决拉克罗斯最持久、最痛苦的谜团似乎是显而易见的答案。因此，在1958年，霍华德雇佣了一些私家侦探来调查伊芙琳·哈特利的失踪。当拉克罗斯警方拒绝与他们分享档案时，他们遇到了障碍。结果，他们浪费了时间、资源和金钱去调查那些已经被排除嫌疑的嫌疑人。当霍华德·乔治的行为公开后，他那小而简朴的家被洗劫一空，尽管什么也没丢。
After he passed away and their funds dried up, the private investigators had to reluctantly cease their involvement. In a final report, they noted the innumerable unanswered questions that remained and concluded. The Evelyn Hartley disappearance will always be a thorn in the city of La Crosse's side until solved. It was around 5 p.m. on Saturday, November 16, 1957, when Deputy Sheriff Frank Warden approached the entrance of a hardware store in the Wisconsin town of Plainfield. He tried the door only to discover it was locked.
在他去世且资金耗尽后，私家侦探不得不勉强停止了他们的参与。在最后一份报告中，他们指出了无数悬而未决的问题，并总结道：“伊芙琳·哈特利失踪案在破案前将永远是拉克罗斯市的一根刺。”1957年11月16日星期六下午5点左右，副警长弗兰克·沃登（Frank Warden）走近威斯康星州普莱恩菲尔德（Plainfield）镇一家五金店的入口。他试了试门，却发现门锁着。
Frank was puzzled. The hardware store was owned by his mother, 58-year-old Bernice, and Frank had arrived to help her out before closing time in one hour. As it turned out, no one had been inside the hardware store since earlier that morning. Customers had approached, but finding the shop locked up, they assumed it was closed. At 9.30 a.m., the store's truck was witnessed pulling out of the garage at the rear of the property and driving away. Frank broke into the store.
弗兰克很困惑。五金店是他母亲、58岁的伯尼斯（Bernice）拥有的，弗兰克本打算在关门前一小时赶来帮她。事实证明，那天早上早些时候之后，五金店里就没人了。顾客们曾走近，但发现店门锁着，以为已经关门了。上午9点30分，有人目击该店的卡车从房产后部的车库开出并驶离。弗兰克破门进入了商店。
He didn't find his mother, but the cash register was open and there was a small pool of blood behind the counter. There was also a receipt written in his mother's handwriting for a gallon of antifreeze. Frank recalled that the previous evening a local handyman had been asking about antifreeze and had promised to return to pick up a gallon the next day. A few hours later, police found the man at a nearby grocery store and placed him under arrest. Meanwhile, other officers drove out to the man's property.
他没有找到他的母亲，但收银机开着，柜台后面有一小滩血迹。还有一张他母亲亲笔写的收据，上面写着一加仑防冻液。弗兰克回想起前一天晚上，一名当地的杂工曾询问过防冻液，并承诺第二天回来取一加仑。几个小时后，警方在附近的一家杂货店找到了那个人并将他逮捕。与此同时，其他警官开车前往那个人的房产。
He lived alone in a large weatherboard farmhouse that had belonged to his parents. The residents sat within a 155-acre farm, much of which was cloaked in snow and dotted with bare trees. Overall, it had a grim and gloomy atmosphere. A sheriff's deputy made his way towards a shed. He walked inside and was immediately confronted by the naked body of Bernice Warden hanging upside down from a crossbar. Her wrists were bound with rope and she had been beheaded.
他独自住在一栋属于他父母的大型木板农舍里。住宅坐落在一个155英亩的农场内，大部分被积雪覆盖，点缀着光秃秃的树木。总的来说，它有一种阴森凄凉的气氛。一名副警长走向一个棚屋。他走进里面，立刻面对着伯尼斯·沃登赤裸的尸体，她被倒挂在横梁上。她的手腕被绳子绑着，而且已经被斩首。
She had also been gutted like a deer with her internal organs removed. Inside the nearby farmhouse, police found Bernice's organs wrapped inside a dress. Her head was also there. The handyman would confess to entering the hardware store and marching straight to the back where guns were displayed for sale. He'd taken down a .22 caliber rifle, which Bernice Warden assumed he wanted to purchase. As she stood waiting to ring it up for him, the handyman loaded it with one bullet he'd brought from home, then fired a single shot into Bernice's head.
她还像鹿一样被开膛破肚，内脏被取出。在附近的农舍里，警方发现了用裙子包裹着的伯尼斯的内脏。她的头也在那里。那名杂工承认进入五金店，径直走到后面陈列枪支待售的地方。他取下一支.22口径步枪，伯尼斯·沃登以为他想买。当她站在那里等着为他结账时，杂工装上了一颗他从家里带来的子弹，然后向伯尼斯的头部开了一枪。
He'd then taken her body to his house, where he mutilated it. He had been busy. A search of the man's farmhouse uncovered another 10 female skulls, some of which had been put on top of bed posts. He'd upholstered chairs with human skin, made masks from women's faces, and a belt out of nipples. Female genitals that had been removed were found stashed in a shoebox. The handyman was 51-year-old Edward Gein, better known as Ed.
然后他把她的尸体带回了家，在那里进行了肢解。他一直很忙。对该男子农舍的搜查发现了另外10个女性头骨，其中一些被放在床柱上。他用人皮装饰椅子，用女人的脸制作面具，用乳头制作腰带。被切除的女性生殖器被发现藏在鞋盒里。这名杂工是51岁的爱德华·盖恩（Edward Gein），也就是众所周知的埃德（Ed）。
He would come to be known as one of the most notorious killers in American history, with his crimes providing the inspiration for novels and films such as Psycho and Silence of the Lambs. Gein had a fixation with his mother, who had been a devout Christian. She'd preached to her sons about the immorality of the world. Women were especially evil, she said, with the exception of herself. They were promiscuous and used to do the devil's bidding. Gein's father died, and then his brother, leaving just Gein and his mother.
他后来被称为美国历史上最臭名昭著的杀手之一，他的罪行激发了《惊魂记》和《沉默的羔羊》等小说和电影的灵感。盖恩对他那虔诚的基督徒母亲有着病态的依恋。她曾向儿子们宣扬世界的堕落，并称除了她自己以外，所有的女性都是邪恶的。她说她们淫乱，是魔鬼的帮凶。盖恩的父亲去世后，他的兄弟也相继离世，只剩下盖恩和他的母亲。
After she suffered a debilitating stroke, Gein devoted himself to her recovery. She died in 1945 at the age of 67, when Gein was 39. Restated and all alone, Gein remained living in the family home, but boarded up the portions of the house his mother had used. His living quarters were reduced to the kitchen and a small room next door. Between 1947 and 1952, Gein visited three nearby cemeteries at night to dig up the graves of recently buried women. As he took the bodies home with him and mutilated them, he particularly focused on the corpses
母亲中风瘫痪后，盖恩全身心地投入到照顾她的康复中。1945年，67岁的母亲去世，当时盖恩39岁。盖恩孤身一人，继续住在家里，但他封死了母亲生前使用过的房间。他的生活空间缩减到了厨房和隔壁的一间小屋。1947年至1952年间，盖恩在夜间多次前往附近的三座墓地，挖掘刚下葬的女性坟墓。他把尸体带回家并进行肢解，他特别关注那些
of middle-aged women who resembled his mother, though body parts belonging to adolescent girls were also found in his house. His dream was to create a suit of human skin that looked like his mother, so he could wear it and become her. As well as admitting to killing Bernice Warden, Gein said he'd murdered a tavern owner named Mary Hogan. She had been missing since 1954, and her head was recovered from his house. The gruesome crimes of Ed Gein led to him being dubbed the Butcher of Plainfield.
长相酷似他母亲的中年女性尸体，尽管在他的家中也发现了属于少女的身体部位。他的梦想是制作一套看起来像他母亲的人皮套装，这样他就可以穿上它，变成她。除了承认杀害伯尼斯·沃登外，盖恩还称自己谋杀了酒馆老板玛丽·霍根。她自1954年起失踪，她的头颅后来在他的家中被发现。埃德·盖恩的残忍罪行使他被称为“普莱恩菲尔德屠夫”。
He was ultimately diagnosed with schizophrenia and deemed not guilty by reason of insanity. Gein spent the remainder of his life in a hospital for the criminally insane. It was said that on the night Evelyn Hartley disappeared in 1953, Ed Gein had been visiting relatives who lived in or near La Crosse. La Crosse was where Gein was born before his family relocated more than 100 miles east to Plainfield. Hartley case investigators interviewed Gein for more than an hour in relation to the crime. He told them that he hadn't been to La Crosse since his family left when he was eight.
他最终被诊断出患有精神分裂症，并被判定因精神错乱而无罪。盖恩在一家刑事精神病院度过了余生。据称，1953年伊芙琳·哈特利失踪的那晚，埃德·盖恩正在探望住在拉克罗斯或附近的亲戚。拉克罗斯是盖恩出生的地方，后来他的家人搬到了向东100多英里外的普莱恩菲尔德。哈特利案件的调查人员曾就此案对他进行了超过一小时的审讯。他告诉他们，自从八岁随家人离开后，他就再没去过拉克罗斯。
Evelyn Hartley's dental records were compared to the remains found in Gein's home. None were a match. The manner in which Evelyn was attacked was inconsistent with Ed Gein's murders operandi. He was only confirmed to have killed two middle-aged women whom he knew and who reminded him of his mother. In both instances he murdered them with a firearm. The rest of the female body parts found in his farmhouse were the result of his grave robbing.
伊芙琳·哈特利的牙科记录与在盖恩家中发现的遗骸进行了比对，结果并不匹配。伊芙琳遇袭的方式与埃德·盖恩的作案手法不符。他只被证实杀害了两名他认识且让他想起母亲的中年女性。在这两起案件中，他都是用枪支杀害了她们。在他农舍中发现的其他女性身体部位都是他盗墓的结果。
In contrast, Evelyn was unknown to Gein, was in the wrong age group, and the evidence from the crime scene was nothing like Gein's confirmed murders. Investigators ruled Ed Gein out as a possible perpetrator in the Hartley case. As the 50th anniversary of Evelyn Hartley's disappearance approached in 2003, local newspaper The La Crosse Tribune published a number of articles reflecting on the case. One focused on the efforts of a local history buff who was determined to solve it. A real tire in La Crosse by day, Andrew Thompson had a fascination with unsolved mysteries that occupied his spare time.
相比之下，伊芙琳是盖恩不认识的人，年龄段也不符，且犯罪现场的证据与盖恩已证实的谋杀案完全不同。调查人员排除了埃德·盖恩作为哈特利案嫌疑人的可能。2003年，随着伊芙琳·哈特利失踪50周年的临近，当地报纸《拉克罗斯论坛报》发表了一系列回顾该案的文章。其中一篇聚焦于一位决心破案的当地历史爱好者的努力。安德鲁·汤普森白天在拉克罗斯做轮胎生意，业余时间则沉迷于未解之谜。
When his business partner Peggy Lovejoy told him about their town's very own ongoing mystery, Andrew was intrigued. He and Peggy began looking into the Hartley case with some help from local police. They also hired a former La Crosse Tribune journalist named Susan Hassell as they wished to publish a book about Evelyn and needed a writer. Soon, an article detailing their efforts ran in the paper. When a local man named Mel Williams read the article, his mind began to tick. One night in 1969, Mel visited a bar owned by his brother in the Wisconsin town of La
当他的商业伙伴佩吉·洛夫乔伊告诉他镇上这个悬而未决的谜团时，安德鲁非常感兴趣。在当地警方的帮助下，他和佩吉开始调查哈特利案。他们还聘请了一位名叫苏珊·哈塞尔的前《拉克罗斯论坛报》记者，因为他们想出版一本关于伊芙琳的书，需要一位作家。不久，一篇详细介绍他们努力的文章在报纸上刊登。当当地人梅尔·威廉姆斯读到这篇文章时，他的思绪开始转动。1969年的一晚，梅尔拜访了他兄弟在威斯康星州拉
Farge, about 40 miles southeast of La Crosse. A group of patrons, including Mel, stayed until after closing, talking and drinking into the early hours. One of them was Clyde Tywee Peterson, a small man with a drinking problem and a reputation for stealing. Despite this, Mel found Peterson likeable and amusing. As the drinks flowed, Peterson began telling a story about how he used to smuggle whiskey into a ward that housed alcoholics at a local psychiatric hospital.
法奇镇拥有的一家酒吧，该镇位于拉克罗斯东南约40英里处。包括梅尔在内的一群顾客一直待到打烊后，在凌晨时分还在喝酒聊天。其中一人是克莱德·泰威·彼得森，一个有酗酒问题且有偷窃前科的矮个子男人。尽管如此，梅尔觉得彼得森为人风趣且讨人喜欢。随着酒兴渐浓，彼得森开始讲述他过去如何将威士忌走私到当地一家精神病院的酗酒者病房的故事。
The man who was present named Whitey Barclay asked, That's about the time you hauled that Hartley girl down there, that right? Peterson avoided the question, but Whitey persisted. You hauled her from La Crosse down to another address and back to La Crosse, huh? Peterson initially said no. Whitey was insistent. You did haul her up there, though, he repeated. Peterson finally replied, No witness, no proof, they haven't found her, have they?
在场的一名男子怀蒂·巴克利问道：“那是不是你把那个哈特利女孩带到那儿的时候？对吧？”彼得森回避了这个问题，但怀蒂坚持追问：“你把她从拉克罗斯带到另一个地址，然后再带回拉克罗斯，对吧？”彼得森起初否认。怀蒂坚持道：“你确实把她带到那儿了，对吧？”彼得森最终回答：“没有证人，没有证据，他们还没找到她，不是吗？”
Others listening in on the conversation asked who the Hartley girl was. Whitey explained Evelyn Hartley's abduction and implicated two other men in the crime as well. Allegedly, Jack had met Evelyn when they attended the same parties. He had known she was babysitting at the Rasmussen's that night. He, Clyde Peterson, and the other unnamed man abducted Evelyn, then later killed her at a house elsewhere. Whitey claimed he had been the one to dig Evelyn's grave in a supposed location in
其他听到谈话的人询问哈特利女孩是谁。怀蒂解释了伊芙琳·哈特利的绑架案，并暗示另外两名男子也参与了犯罪。据称，杰克在参加同一派对时认识了伊芙琳。他知道她那天晚上在拉斯穆森家做保姆。他和克莱德·彼得森以及另一名未具名的男子绑架了伊芙琳，随后在别处的一所房子里杀害了她。怀蒂声称他曾在一个据称位于
La Farge. The conversation lasted about seven minutes. Then, Whitey noticed a device Mel Williams had brought with him to the bar that night. Mel was visiting from Nashville, Tennessee, where he'd relocated to in an attempt to become a country music star. Bands were performing at the bar earlier that evening, so Mel had set up a reel-to-reel recorder to tape their sets. He had left it on long after the music stopped, capturing the conversation between Clyde
拉法奇的地方挖了伊芙琳的坟墓。谈话持续了大约七分钟。随后，怀蒂注意到了梅尔·威廉姆斯当晚带到酒吧的一个设备。梅尔当时从田纳西州的纳什维尔赶来，他为了成为乡村音乐明星搬到了那里。那天晚上早些时候有乐队在酒吧表演，所以梅尔架设了一台卷盘式录音机来录制他们的演出。音乐停止后，他一直没关录音机，捕捉到了克莱德·
Tywee Peterson and Whitey Barclay about Evelyn Hartley's murder. Upon noticing the recording device, Whitey told Mel to turn it off, and the conversation was dropped. Mel knew Jack at golf air, and believed he was capable of killing someone. He would later describe him to author Susan Hassell as violent and vicious, but thought little of the conversation at the time due to how drunk the men were. Maybe they were just trying to big-note themselves. He would later toss the tape recorded at the bar that night into a box, along with dozens
泰威·彼得森和怀蒂·巴克利关于伊芙琳·哈特利谋杀案的谈话。注意到录音设备后，怀蒂让梅尔关掉它，谈话随之中断。梅尔认识杰克·阿特戈尔，并认为他有杀人的能力。他后来向作家苏珊·哈塞尔描述他时称其暴力且恶毒，但当时由于这些人喝得烂醉，他没把谈话当回事。也许他们只是在吹牛。后来，他把那天晚上在酒吧录下的磁带和几十个
of others he'd made over the years. On the 50th anniversary of Evelyn Hartley's disappearance was making headlines, Mel retrieved the tape he'd made at the bar 34 years prior, which had captured the confession. Now 76 years old, Mel passed the recording to those collaborating on the book about Evelyn's case. They in turn handed it to the authorities. Others described the tape as the best lead we've ever had. However, Clyde Tywee Peterson, Jack at golf air, and the third man implicated in the
他多年来制作的其他磁带一起扔进了一个盒子里。在伊芙琳·哈特利失踪50周年之际，此事成为头条新闻，梅尔找出了他34年前在酒吧录下的那盘磁带，里面记录了那段供词。当时76岁的梅尔将录音交给了正在合作撰写伊芙琳案件书籍的人。他们随后将其交给了当局。其他人称这盘磁带是“我们有史以来最好的线索”。然而，克莱德·泰威·彼得森、杰克·阿特戈尔以及第三名涉案人员
crime were all deceased. Golf air had taken his own life on Christmas Day 1967. Amitur Sluth Andrew Thompson visited Whitey Barclay's wife. She believed Evelyn Hartley had been in Lafarge the night before she vanished. She took Andrew to meet her husband. By this time, Whitey had dementia and was living in a nursing home. When Evelyn's name was mentioned, the elderly man froze, but did not speak. Lafarge was one of the locations where the denim jacket and shoes that were believed
都已经去世了。阿特戈尔于1967年圣诞节自杀身亡。业余侦探安德鲁·汤普森拜访了怀蒂·巴克利的妻子。她认为伊芙琳·哈特利在失踪前一天曾在拉法奇。她带安德鲁去见了她的丈夫。此时，怀蒂患有痴呆症，住在疗养院。当提到伊芙琳的名字时，这位老人僵住了，但没有说话。拉法奇是曾展示过被认为
to belong to Evelyn's abductors had been put on display. Rumors had spread amongst locals that the jacket was familiar. They'd seen an acquaintance of Peterson and golf airs wearing it before. Some have speculated that it was Peterson who wore the jacket. He was a small man and it was a small size. The good rich sneakers recovered were believed to have been worn by two men at different times, one who was very tall and the other shorter. Peterson was known to wear secondhand clothing.
属于伊芙琳绑架者的牛仔夹克和鞋子的地方之一。当地人传言说这件夹克很眼熟。他们以前见过彼得森和阿特戈尔的一个熟人穿过它。有人推测是彼得森穿了这件夹克。他个子矮小，而那件夹克尺码很小。回收的古德里奇运动鞋被认为曾由两名男子在不同时间穿过，一人非常高，另一人较矮。彼得森以穿二手衣服而闻名。
Investigators had made inquiries about Clyde Peterson and Jack Golf Air back in 1968. It was unclear how the men came to be on their radar, but they later said they'd never been able to substantiate claims they had killed Evelyn. When investigators looked into the men again in 2004, they were unable to come up with anything concrete tying them to the case. In her book Wears Evelyn, author Susan Hassell mentions the possibility that the men's bodies could one day be assumed for DNA testing. Attempts to obtain DNA evidence from blood found at the crime scene have so far proved
调查人员曾在1968年询问过克莱德·彼得森和杰克·阿特戈尔。目前尚不清楚这些人是如何进入警方视线的，但他们后来表示从未能证实他们杀害伊芙琳的说法。当调查人员在2004年再次调查这些人时，他们无法拿出任何具体的证据将他们与此案联系起来。在她的书《伊芙琳在哪里》中，作者苏珊·哈塞尔提到了未来可能挖掘这些人的尸体进行DNA检测的可能性。从犯罪现场发现的血液中获取DNA证据的尝试迄今为止都
unsuccessful. Susan Hassell published Wears Evelyn in 2005 after extensive research alongside Andrew Thompson and Peggy Lovejoy. As well as coming through archives and police files, Susan interviewed residents of La Crosse who spoke about the loss of innocence experienced by the community in the wake of Evelyn's disappearance. Curfews were introduced, doors were kept locked, girls no longer walked alone, and families struggled to find babysitters.
未获成功。苏珊·哈塞尔在与安德鲁·汤普森和佩吉·洛夫乔伊进行了广泛研究后，于2005年出版了《伊芙琳在哪里》。除了查阅档案和警方文件外，苏珊还采访了拉克罗斯的居民，他们谈到了伊芙琳失踪后社区所经历的纯真丧失。宵禁被实施，门窗紧锁，女孩们不再独自走路，家庭也难以找到保姆。
The Rasmussen family were haunted by the tragedy that had taken place in their home, with Vigo Rasmussen telling a journalist in 1978, It's a nightmare whenever we think of it. I don't mean it preys on our minds constantly, but we don't forget it, no matter how long ago it was. Evelyn's remaining family members were too heartbroken to participate in Susan Hassell's book, but some of her friends gave interviews, including her best friend, a girl named Mary Sequest Wall.
拉斯穆森一家被发生在他们家中的悲剧所困扰，维戈·拉斯穆森在1978年告诉记者：“每当我们想起它，那都是一场噩梦。我并不是说它时刻折磨着我们的心，但无论过去多久，我们都不会忘记。”伊芙琳幸存的家人因过于悲痛而无法参与苏珊·哈塞尔的书，但她的一些朋友接受了采访，包括她最好的朋友，一个名叫玛丽·塞奎斯特·沃尔的女孩。
Mary shared some of her favorite memories with Susan. She recalled Evelyn as someone who loved music and would walk down the street playing a ukulele and singing. Mary joined the Hartleys on their many trips to the great outdoors, and they would all go hiking through the woods together. The girls would have sleepovers and laugh at silly jokes while Evelyn's parents made them popcorn. During one slumber party, Evelyn and her friends snuck out of the house at dawn, still wearing
玛丽与苏珊分享了她最珍贵的一些回忆。她回忆说伊芙琳是一个热爱音乐的人，会一边弹着尤克里里一边唱歌走在街上。玛丽曾多次加入哈特利一家的户外旅行，他们会一起去树林里徒步。女孩们会举行过夜派对，在伊芙琳的父母为她们做爆米花时，她们会因为傻笑话而大笑。在一次过夜派对期间，伊芙琳和她的朋友们在黎明时分溜出家门，身上还穿着
their pajamas, and rode their bicycles over to the local swimming pool. It was closed, but the girls climbed the fence and jumped into the pool. On the day that Evelyn went missing, Mary had passed her driving test and obtained her license. That evening, she felt disappointed that Evelyn was babysitting because she wanted to share the exciting news. At around 7pm, she decided to call her and went to the telephone, but because she didn't know how to spell the surname Rasmussen, she couldn't look up the family's phone number
睡衣，骑着自行车去了当地的游泳池。虽然游泳池关门了，但女孩们翻过围栏跳进了池子里。在伊芙琳失踪的那天，玛丽刚刚通过了驾驶考试并拿到了驾照。那天晚上，她感到很失望，因为伊芙琳在做保姆，而她想分享这个令人兴奋的消息。晚上7点左右，她决定打电话给她，走到电话机旁，但因为她不知道如何拼写拉斯穆森这个姓氏，她无法在电话簿中
in a phone book. Mary told author Susan Hassell, I put the phone back. I thought I'd talk with Evelyn tomorrow. That was about the time it happened. News soon broke that Evelyn had been taken. Mary explained to Susan Hassell. She changed how I live, I just have a hard time with it. I feel so awful that it had to be her, and she is such a wonderful person.
查到这家的电话号码。玛丽告诉作者苏珊·哈塞尔：“我放下了电话。我想明天再和伊芙琳谈谈。那大约就是事情发生的时间。”不久，伊芙琳被带走的消息传开了。玛丽向苏珊·哈塞尔解释说：“她改变了我的生活方式，我只是很难接受。我感到非常难过，因为那个人竟然是她，她是一个如此美好的人。”
As of mid-2022, Evelyn Hartley's case remains unsolved, her remains have not been found. Richard and Ethel Hartley passed away without learning what happened to their daughter. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
截至2022年中期，伊芙琳·哈特利的案件仍未侦破，她的遗骸尚未找到。理查德和埃塞尔·哈特利在去世前都没能得知女儿的遭遇。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。